Rocha is absolutely lovely to see his
day of course we've seen you this season
on Game of Thrones shooting the purple
wedding I'd tell me all about that we
took a public park for a month and we
dressed that we put in fountains and
fish that had not been there previously
we put in a giant lion said from which
actors could emerge they put in tables I
had food they had doves on the pie and I
said to the director
all this will be the telly and he said
no no no it's a 70 hour movie that
contextualizes it that's what's so
extraordinary about Game of Thrones in
general is that it's not telly it's
there's some adventures of life event
familiar with the show when you came on
board or they you boned up didn't you on
the box set for season two so what was
your reaction when they staged Joffrey's
death in that purple wedding scene well
I knew it was coming you see we have the
scripts that's the problem it's a being
in a show isn't the same thing as
watching a show and sharing it it's a
much more technical process and moreover
of course you've only seen Joffrey died
once on Spain but we saw him do it
several times from several different
camera angles so the one thing that
isn't different about this job is that
it's an acting job and you just get up
and do it interesting Lee also the trial
you were an important member of as well
Tyrians trial which was just seen
recently something a little bit about
shooting that well that was the one way
that was the first thing I did when I
wasn't quite sure the relationship
between the characters it was a fairly
vitriolic blog about how I should have
boned up on because actually there was
some time between being cast and Southey
it was cast one week out to Belfast
costume fittings and then out again to
start shooting I think I knew a little
about it and it's not uncommon together
with introductory pack and I didn't have
one it was I turn up and there you go so
but it was kind of fun and we thinking
in the past two or three years I dunno I
did a movie Woody Allen in which I
wasn't allowed to see the script
and Alison did a movie at my clean which
I spent several weeks researching the
script so you know you go from one end
to the other which is right neither is
right well acts as we turn up and we
actually what we do now of course you
work with some fantastic actors in the
show charles dancers Tywin you worked
with Dinah reg who plays your mother in
the show and tell me a little bit about
working with those guys and also Peter
Dinklage he plays Tyrion - I went to
begin I mean remarkable people one at
all Peter Dinklage is one of those
remarkable actors I've ever where was
period nothing else to say about it
marvelous man I have worked with Charles
years and years and years and years ago
Charles became a star precipitously for
his role in jewel in the crown and I
went with him on the next show he did I
was a very young actor it might have
been my first tell even and so he was
sort of feeling his way and it was
actually been out of course he's a super
confident super experienced and
excellence in that role and he's a
remarkable performance Diana I mean
everyone who works with the Great Danes
Diana Judi Dench Elaine Eileen Atkins
they also have marvelous these people I
work with Eileen before she's marvelous
so so Diana marvelous actually because
these are people on top of their game
they've got nothing to do a very relaxed
happy fantastic people one of the great
privileges of my life working with Diana
I was great to hear I mean you were
filming the trial in Belfast they
weren't you bright as opposed to create
no Diana we have seen yes she wasn't
Belfast I say I can't remember but
certainly she was in Croatia because the
wedding was shot in Croatia I think she
must have been above us yes yes because
the yes the wedding be oh I'm going to
stop no she's probably in Belfast now of
course we've seen the wedding we've seen
the trial as well what do you think
about the possibility that George RR
Martin's mooted recently about Game of
Thrones movie is that the kind of thing
you'd like seemed you've already said
they shoot the TV show like a movie
but this would be maybe I don't know a
two hour movie yeah it's just going to
be like a super super super big episode
isn't it they do their structured very
carefully and it's a major major bit of
storytelling I love it
you know bring it on I can't wait I just
can't wait now how likely are we to see
you in the next season because we love
your character in the show you are
certainly likely to see me in the next
season
it was confirmed yesterday actually and
what would you like to see your
character get up to next time I'd like
to see him singing songs with a lute I
mean I have no idea if you will I
suggest I'm just guessing that's just
what I'd like to do yes and it'd be
quite nice to kind of bring it in but I
should say I've seen none of the scripts
I don't know what's happening there's no
suggestion loosen CEO just I'd quite
like to do
you